the most i know about mma is jake paul
that's not even [ __ ] mma that's
boxing bro there you go
says it all for me that guy that guy's a
funny dude you watched the fight right
we were talking about before we started
oh my god man listen
that whole broadcast was just a a [ __ ]
show
it's crazy but i mean they they did for
the first time doing it i mean
didn't jake paul put that whole thing
together yeah for some kid
for some 25 year old kid to put together
that i mean it's he didn't do bad for
his first time
did you see he came out in the weigh-in
with a robot that was [ __ ] that was
crazy i was like
who comes out with a and his walk out to
the ring he had a big robot
yeah the mascot yeah but uh yeah he's
he's
i mean he's definitely i mean i think
you know what i think i think he knows
what he's doing
yeah he totally does i think i think
he's
doing this to make his name bigger of
course
he's he's smart he's you know what if
you think about it now now now i'm
thinking about it
he's kind of doing what i was doing he
he doesn't need to fight the best
fighter for what
why fight the best fight when i could be
knocking out these these fools yeah
and it looks good i mean think of the
audience that he's bringing to boxing
crazy
he's bringing this whole young new
demographic this whole demographic
of kids that watch youtube to boxing and
did you notice something i bet you
that's something that you didn't realize
he made that fight exactly
the same time as fight night which is
ufc
did he really yep there was a ufc fight
at the same time the
finals in that was at the same time
because dana white bet a million bucks
that he'd lose he don't like dana white
he'll know he doesn't like dana white
they don't know it doesn't like him
so that's why he did it he he put it so
so so when i was trying to watch it
i i had my ufc fight on because i wanted
to watch the whitaker fight which is
huge and gastelum
and then i had his fight on the corner
of the tv
watch trying to watch that at the same
time yeah
yeah so so he's he's definitely smart
he's definitely
he definitely knows what he's doing i
don't think he's gonna fight any real
fighter who can strike because
once he loses that's it who would be who
do you think would be
a real fighter on his level that he
could fight next that he would that
would be a fair match
he should fight one of the girls man
seriously he's not going to do that
right you should do that that would be
cool
that would be cool like who is a
legitimate who do you think would be a
legitimate contender for him who's a
boxer
who do you think who do you boxing i
don't know any boxers you know anybody i
just know mostly though you know his
brother's gonna fight floyd mayweather
yeah he's gonna get but you know see
i wouldn't i would fight floyd
mayweather because he's a little guy
well no because
i know floyd mayweather's not gonna
freaking try to put my head he's not
going to kill you he's
going to put my teeth through my you
know floyd mayweather
you saw he did his last fight yeah right
did you see what he did to the japanese
dude in japan you ever seen that one no
oh that one's even more funny that was
more funny
he kind of just well he he he's uh he's
he's the best defensive boxer right
that's what his thing is
he drags you into deep water until you
run out of gas and plus he'll toy with
you
he's not gonna try he's not gonna try to
hurt you i mean he did to conor mcgregor
too
kind of like toyed with him a little bit
you know defense defense hit him a
little bit
so so paul paul is uh
uh what's his name again jake jake paul
jake or logan paul logan paul
is going to fight floyd logan paul's
going to be fine he he's he's not going
to get him
he's not going to get hurt so he's going
to be like that's a fun fight he's going
to make a lot of money
it's going to be a fun publicity tour
yeah yeah yeah you know
yeah and and mayweather loves money so
oh hell yeah that publicity tour for the
connor versus
uh mayweather [ __ ] that was that was
crazy that was hard to not walk i mean
that was [ __ ] so entertaining that
was really good
every single event they did and conor
did good man
kind of oh he's a funny [ __ ]
dude yo so
i thought i thought the original fight
was going to be connor
but i think connor doesn't want to even
bother with it i think oh you mean
against jake yeah
because he was calling out his wife
i need more money than that buddy yeah
yeah so i think no connor thinks he's on
a whole another level then which he is
but you know he could probably he could
make a lot of money by doing it
but if conor lost it'd make him look so
much worse
i think conor would be a legitimate
fighting contender for jake paul
honestly because connor's not
a traditional boxer right right right
right but i think jake paul has no
chance
against boxing connor yeah really i'll
tell you why
because conor doesn't fight like a box
he he
he's khan is a really good striker but
his striking style is not it's not
normal like he
i i think jake paul will yeah i think
knows no chance
even mayweather looks even mayweather
had a little problem in the beginning
with him
you know kind of just has a weird the
way he puts his guard the way his hands
are like here like he keeps a hand out
here
and yeah like that and it's now you have
to watch this handle you have to watch
this at the same time
like i think jake paul will have a hard
time only because the style
is gonna be it's really tricky like yeah
even mayweather got tagged a couple of
times man yeah he did
a lot of times because of that style is
just so weird man like you don't know
where those punches are coming from
but he says nate diaz he called out nate
diaz so they days would whoop his ass i
want to see this i wonder
is a [ __ ] big lanky guy yeah yeah
but nadia's is a jiu jitsu guy so i
don't know right but he also can strike
i mean it makes it i mean yeah he is
yeah right
when you said you just said i mean he's
like a ground gun yeah it makes it but
it makes it it makes it interesting when
you're a wrestler or a jiu jitsu guy and
then you're
forced to only box i think mentally
that makes it hard for you too because
you you know
as a professional athlete you train
every day
and things become natural so when a
happens b is automatic when c
happens d is automatic now that you're
in this
ring now you have to think i think you
have to overthink now because
you know you want to grab them but you
can't grab them because it's boxing so
don't grab
right so so i think that's what makes it
difficult for a lot of these other
fighters when they're doing this
because they your your brain your body
wants to do one thing natural
you want to grab like you see when
connor kind of kept trying to
hit him in the back of the head oh he
started like hammering
can't do that [ __ ] boy the hairball
punches are funny man you can't try the
hammer punch
yeah you can't do that so i think that
makes a little difficult for them
but yeah for sure i want to see how far
jake paul is going to take but it is
kind of like
the thing is i mean i've had a lot a
couple arguments with friends about you
know
how legit jake and logan are compared to
other boxers and
you know some people be like oh it's
just discrediting the sport or it's just
making it
it's it's it's just it's disrespecting
the sport and the history of boxing i
don't think it's disrespecting the sport
i mean it's it's the the guy can box he
can fight it's not like
it's not right it's not and what's
what's
the point of it the point is to get
people to watch it and to pre and to
and to make money right yeah yeah no no
no he can he the the duke can fight
don't don't get me wrong they can fight
and they can sell it they can sell a
fight listen
if you knock somebody out for 15 minutes
with a glove on then you can fight then
you've got some power i don't care who
it is
i mean if you when when he knocked out
nate robinson
that's 15 minutes dude was out and this
is a professional professional athlete
what do you mean he was out he was out
for 15 minutes it was like 15 minutes
like
it was a last remember exact number you
should check but i think it was 15
minutes he was out out
like like people were worried that's
scary right
he hit him hard and it was like it
didn't even look like a punch either it
was like a
like a little like a short half punch
like an undercut like under this power
power and it didn't even look like that
thing could have knocked him out
and the ben asked her punch was
hilarious oh my god
bro he hit the ground like a [ __ ]
bricks
that was really really hard too but yeah
but he got up and he was ready to go
back at it yeah i think they should have
let him fight i don't know she didn't
fight too
i i think she let him fight because he's
an mma fighter he's used to taking that
he's used to getting his head punched